the Latvian Gambit
that is E4 E5 Knight to F3 and now the
move F5 is a very dangerous and
aggressive response by black and
specially if you don't know how to react
then you can find yourself at the
troubled Zone
but don't worry as today is your lucky
day
because after watching this video Until
the End not only you are going to
equipped
with a surprise weapon against this
Gambit
but overall this opening will never
bother you for the lifetime
so fasten up your seat belt and let's
get started
[Music]
well as you can see I highlighted by the
arrows white has many choices
and theory is very big in all these
moves however I am going to recommend a
simple approach here and that start with
Knight to C3
and I can certainly claim that if this
move does not provide the reputation at
least it creates some huge problem for
the black camp
okay let's focus on database there are
three major choices and let's see each
button to find out what is the problem
from the black side
the first move I want to consider is f
captures E4
by far the most popular choice
and after this if white is foolish
enough to take on e4 with the Knight
then black can play D5 and enjoy all
sorts of fun
but white is equally smart and he should
start with Knight captures E5
where the threat is very obvious you
want to play Queen to H5 check and nap
The Rook in the corner
well accordingly black has tried three
choices and amongst them the main lines
start with Knight to F6
whereupon I am going to Advocate two
approaches
if you are a solid player and really
like the pawn advantageous middle game
then you can go for the following
sequence that is Knight to G4 and after
this however black Wiggles he is going
to lose upon
so for example after D5 we can take this
Knight and after Queen takes we can give
this check
which at the end let's say queen F7
Queen takes King takes
Knight xd5 and Bishop to D6
subtly wins the pawn and black ass
absolutely no compensation about it
so I guess this is the easiest and
safest line if you want to play against
Knight to F6
well if you are like me who likes
tactical battles then I can certainly
recommend you go ahead with the mainline
stop starting with Bishop to C4
so that we are looking at Juicy F7
Square
but
problem is can't black can play D5 here
and neutralize all of the threats
well believe me this is exactly white
ones as we are going to surprise black
here with this nice peace sacrifice
boom
what a move
pay special attention guys to this
tactical pattern as it going to happen
in many of this left-win gamut
variations
the big point is after Knight captures
D5 we are going to deliver this check
and King to E7 is completely out of the
equation as after Queen to F7 apparently
there is a Checkmate in nine so you can
try it by yourself
so that's why G6 is more or less forced
and after this yup you guessed it Knight
captures G6 what else
where Whitehead sets up a cunning trap
here
and if you look at the database in the
majority of the cases black has tried
the move Knight to F6 which is in fact a
very bad choice and after this white is
completely winning with this wonderful
check
it doesn't matter however Black Blocks
the next move we are going to munch the
rook and at just 10th move of the game
we are exchange up
so this Knight to F6 idea in majority of
the cases get failed due to this lie
okay that means black has to take this
Knight
and although white can take the Rook
here I propose this aggressive approach
Queen captures G6
whereupon black has two choices
if you think that King to E7 is the
right one then I'm really sorry because
after this by force white is winning
with the following sequence
Queen to G5 check
King to E8
and now you deliver this nasty check
again where the end result Queen E7
Queen captures achieved
White House three pawns and a rook
against two knights where black king is
wide open and as per the chess engine it
gives you plus three Advantage which is
almost a huge one
so look at this guys how fascinating
this line is we are almost forcing black
to playing only moves and here after
King to D7
I recommend this straightforward
approach you take on D5
and it doesn't matter however black
respond let's say main line here start
with C6
why take on e4
and after King to C7
just wait for a while and count the
material
white has four pawns for a piece and his
King moving all around the board
and funny enough even though
engine gives only plus one advantage to
wide in terms of practical point of view
this is simply outstanding position to
play over the bow
let me give you a simple line
white plays D4 here
nope black can't take it as the simple
reason is after Bishop to F4 check it
doesn't matter wherever the King goes
the queen will be lost
for example if King to d8 then we have
Rook to D1
and the same story goes if he goes to B6
as this time around black sweetie get
trapped with Bishop to E3
so that is why you can't take on D4 and
you need to prevent this important check
so more or less the force responses the
bishop to D6 afterwards white initiative
run down the board with C4 grabbing the
space threatening C5 so B6
and now you play this very tactical move
Bishop to F4 which by force exchanged
the bishop but at the end when we take
it back
you have two options
the engine's recommendation is a very
safe one castling on the king side
but I propose you should go ahead and
Castle quinside the simple reason is
your king is on the same side as the
black king and you have three connected
passer which can literally run down the
board
and create havoc in the black Gap
so this is the ultimate main line and if
white is getting this all the time he
should be more than happy
okay so apart from Knight to F6 there
are other choices but that doesn't fit
well for example black can already play
a blunder mu here namely D5 happen in
roughly 500 games well after this the
task is very easy
the universal pattern you give this
check G6 you take the spawn and after
Knight to F6 yep you guessed it more or
less same sequence Queen check King to
F7 and Knight captures h8 whereupon
white indeed obtain the exchange at just
eighth move of the cave
so now D5 is a wrong choice by the black
here
I think more interesting is Queen to F6
but this again doesn't help black as we
can continue with D4 protecting the
night threatening Bishop to C4 so black
response is false he has to take it
and although theories suggest F4 here I
recommend this modern chess engine move
Knight captures D3 afterwards
black is having some huge issues
you can already see the engine Evolution
here it says plus 2.2 that means there
is something horribly goes wrong in the
black cam
for example the majority of the games
start with C6 and stopping the ninth
intrusion and planning to play D5
well this can be simply met with this
wonderful Queen check and now black has
two choices
if he blocked the check with the queen
then this is the easiest one you play
Bishop to E3
avoiding the queen exchange and after
the obvious move D5
White Castle on the queen side
the point is
after Knight to F6 we want to play Rook
to even so that after any black moves
let's say Bishop to D7
we can deliver Queen to D2
and I can't stop laughing here because
look at the pathetic position of black
his King side pieces are stuck his Queen
and King are in line for the rook and
black has yet to clear his Queen side
pieces
all in all just look at the engine
Evolution and you can see how pitiable
black position is
probably the most accurate response here
is Bishop to E7
but after this I am going to propose a
new move here which has never been
played and that is G4
and the Big Time idea can be revealed
after D5 and G5 as recently I beat a
2300 in this line where my opponent
played Queen to E6 trying to exchange
Queen
I played Bishop to E3
and now you see the plus side of G5 this
Knight cannot move that means black
cannot Castle on the king side
so my opponent thought okay I'm going to
go on the queen side with Knight to A6
H4 and Bishop to D7
but just one move Bishop to S3 and black
and pack his back and go home
well he tried Queen to D6 a horrible
blunder as Bishop to F4 finished the job
as Queen has only one square to go
namely
G6 but after this
the lightning strike yup you got it
Bishop captures D7 and sadly black can't
even touch this bishop
as his species get [ __ ]
well that's sort of fun you can get in
this line
the second most popular choice here is
nightweb six
but after this I don't think so you have
any trouble to find White's next reply
yup Bishop to C4 going for the same
tactical pattern
okay black has four choices and amongst
them Knight captures E4 is a fast
blunder by black
because after this we can simply take on
E5
and that is absolutely no way black can
protect on app 7.
okay by far the most popular choice is f
captures e full
but this goes into the same direction
which we have already seen earlier
can you find sequence Let's test you
First We Take only five
threatening on F7 black should play D5
and can you find the key move
yup Knight captures D5 Knight captures
D5
Here Comes this amazing Queen check and
after G6 Knight takes G6 Pawn takes G6
and queen takes G6
finally we reach to our critical
position via King to D7 Bishop captures
D5
where white octane four points for a
piece and as we have seen earlier this
is practically a fun position to play
over the book
well Knight to C6 here will transpose to
our next chapter
so the only move left is D6
and after this
we have this nice jab in the center
namely D4
well F captures E4 is by far the most
popular choice but I'm afraid after this
white get winning position with Knight
to G5
and the threat is very obvious not only
you are looking at Juicy F7 square but
when black plays D5 we have this nice
tactical shot namely D captures E5
the point is after the base sequence D
capture C4 Queen captures d8 King
captures d8 Pawn takes F6
threatening Knight to f74 so black
response is foes he has to play King to
E8 but now we can save up a pawn with
this check
and there is a high profile game in the
database which goes like this King to E7
white Place Bishop to E3
and after that six he simply delivered
this check keeping the king away from
the pawn so that now he can safely
recapture on e4 and at the end not only
white has Superior peace development
with an extra Pawn but he has a
tremendous attack coming up with Castle
on the queen side
foreign
can be successfully met with Knight
captures D4 attacking on F5
and when black take on e4
we can Castle on the king side setting
up a high profile trap here
as the majority of the games continue
with defy
where you know your stuff
yup this wonderful night sacrifice where
at the end result Knight takes Queen
check G6 and this time around instead of
taking the night you can go for more
with Queen to E5 check so that we can
nap The Rook in the corner
and what else 11th move and exchange of
position
last but not least what to do against
the Moon Knight to C6
well the answer is very simple we have
this typical jab in the center
and black has three choices
the first move Knight to F6 is probably
the easiest one because after this we
directly transpose to the main line with
the following move order
Knight captures E5
Pawn takes E4
Bishop to C4 D Phi and yo Knight
captures D5 Knight captures D5 Queen
track G6 Knight takes G6
G6
Queen takes G6
and
after King to D7 and Bishop to D5 I
think this is even the bad version of it
because black has already committed this
Knight on C6
which is not ideal as it blocking the
view of the king
and if you think that black can get away
with Knight captures D4 then think twice
as after this
black is losing his Queen
how let's check out first we play Bishop
to G5 attacking the queen
black has to play Bishop to V7 and after
this this nice peace sacrifice Bishop to
E6
enable the answer as after Knight to E6
and the move Rook to D1
black shoot resigned the game
well the same story goes if he continue
with f captures E4 the second choice
whereupon
yup we go 95 and after Knight to F6 we
play Bishop to C4 inviting black to play
D5 so that we can sack overnight and
enter into the same position
so finally let's check out what is going
to happen after the unique move e
captures D4
well against this my recommendation is
you take it with the Knight
and since we are attacking on fi black
has two choices number one if we take on
e4 then this is pretty bad one as after
the following continuation Knight takes
C6 B Tech C6 Queen check
you can't play G6 as your rook in the
corner hangs so by force black has to
play King to E7
but I am afraid this is getting worse
news as white has another dazzling
sacrifice here
not to defy
and the point is after Pawn takes Queen
if I check
King to F7 and now Queen captures D5
where the end we get exchanged at yet
another 11th move of the game
foreign
ER house black should take this Knight
but after this we can take back with the
queen and as we are threatening on F5
the majority of the games continue with
app captures E4
we continue with our Lightning Fast
development with Bishop to F4
and after Knight to F6 and long Castle
I think black is already busted as
engine evaluate this position plus three
for white and to illustrate my point I
like to show you a model Grand Master
game from here where black plays C6
trying to get D5 in
so white plays Knight takes E4 attacking
on F6 Knight twice
black eliminate this Knight but
unfortunately this is exactly why it
wants as after this queen check
sadly enough black has to block it with
the queen as Bishop to E7 can run into
Bishop to D6 and Rook to E1 losing the
piece
okay so Queen E7 what else and after
this I think any good chess player can
demonstrate the winning combination
First Step you avoid the queen and when
black plays D5 you take out your Bishop
so that if the chance has been given we
can Munch The Black Queen
well in the game black desperately tried
Queen F7 but after rookchak Bishop to E7
when you are so far behind in
development
tactics really killed you and this is
exactly happened to Black
white delivered Bishop to G5
threatening the queen and Bishop so
black plays Bishop to E6
but this is just delaying the
unavoidable
why took it and after Queen takes
last thing you don't play Bishop to F5
here as Queen to G5 is good for black so
wisely enough white plays F4 and after
this black resigns s even if you move
the king out of the E file the bishop to
F5 cannot be avoidable
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this
surprising reputa against the Latvian
Gambit
remember at this point you want to play
Knight to C3
and after this I think however black
plays he get a disgusting position
and as I have demonstrated in this video
in most of the lines it is white who
enjoy all sorts of fun from the opening
and I think it is your responsibility to
realize black to forget about this
Gambit and look out for the good
alternatives
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I will see you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care